je reçois à présent dans cette édition
du 7 8 du 2 avril Blandine Bâle qui est
Hugues Bertaux bonsoir à tous les deux
vous êtes membre du collège qui c'est le
conseil en développement de 50 ans en
Yvelines nous avons déjà eu l'occasion
d'en parler sur ce plateau vous le savez
le codeski regroupe des associatifs des
particuliers des bénévoles qui donnent
leur point de vue leurs analyses sur
différents problèmes différents
problématiques qui concernent
l'agglomération dans le cadre de la
Semaine du Développement Durable vous
venez sur le plateau ce soir pour
évoquer le rendez-vous du 4 avril vous
allez animer un atelier débat sur les
déplacements écologiques cette
thématique déjà vous l'avez abordée au
sein du podeski avant même ce
rendez-vous du 4 avril ça fait parmi
partie des problématiques importantes
oui bien sûr dans le cadre du côté ski 4
nous avons commencé par parler
d'environnement en matière de transport
et en matière d'aménagement
et donc nous avons proposé quatre
ateliers sur les thèmes des déplacements
sur le territoire des 50 chinois donc à
destination des habitants et des usagers
de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin donc
ça c'est pour le rendez-vous du 4 avril
il sera ouvert à tout le monde et ça
aussi c'est une première puisque
d'habitude vous travaillez entre vous
entre personnes qui ont été nommées au
sein du codeski et donc quatre ateliers
quatre réflexions oui donc
toute personne intéressée par par les
sujets de
déplacement peuvent s'inscrire sur le
site de la Communauté d'Agglomération ou
en tapant codeski
donc le premier atelier je vais donner
la parole
justement vous êtes vous occuper de
l'atelier qui traite de la pratique de
déplacement en Île-de-France quelles
sont ces pratiques de déplacement en
Île-de-France c'est ce que déjà il y a
une sensibilité écologique de respect de
l'environnement un petit peu ou pas du
tout parce qu'on prend beaucoup sa
voiture aujourd'hui encore oui on peut
dire que
67% des
des ménages des déplacements des ménages
à montrer un forte proportion de
déplacement par le la voiture donc on
peut dire que c'est le facteur qui qui
contribue le plus dans le contexte
écologique à générer des gaz à effet de
serre et c'est aussi il faut bien le
dire l'explication de ce thème de cette
rencontre débat qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine du développement durable et pour
lequel il est essentiel de réfléchir
d'échanger les idées et de faire monter
aux élus des propositions
visant à améliorer changer les
comportements et utiliser les les tous
les modes de transport possibles se
limitant pas la voiture bien évidemment
et ça veut dire qu'à l'issue de
l'atelier débat qui sera organisé le 4
avril la date et le lieu ce sont
affichés sur sur votre écran c'est à la
communauté d'agglomération ATRAP à
partir de 18h30 donc à l'issue de ces
ateliers de débat il y aura un compte
rendu et ce sera transmis directement
aux différents élus oui on peut
l'indiquer et la proposition
issue de cet échange sera
remontée aux élus et
accessible sur le site internet de la
communauté d'agglomération et du côté
ski donc chacun pourra effectivement
consulter et surtout déjà venir
participer vous êtes en charge des
ateliers qui vont évoquer les pratiques
de déplacement en Île-de-France vous
êtes en charge de l'atelier qui traitera
du partage de l'espace public parce
qu'il faut de la place pour tout le
monde on ne peut pas mettre la voiture
aux oubliettes utiliser uniquement le
vélo aujourd'hui l'espace est déjà bien
partagé il y en tout cas ça s'engage
chacun arrive à trouver ses marques
alors l'objectif c'est de bien vivre
ensemble et de d'avoir un partage de la
chaussée qui soit le plus agréable pour
tous les usagers c'est à dire pour les
automobilistes pour les motos pour les
cyclistes mais également pour les
piétons les usagers des transports en
commun et tous les véhicules de service
donc avec la multiplication une voiture
c'est vrai que le partage de la chaussée
est parfois conflictuel donc trouver des
alternatives pour mieux vivre ensemble
et que chacun trouve la place la
meilleure avec la signalisation adaptée
justement comment on fait pour que
chacun s'entende bien sur la route parce
qu'il aura toujours des conflits alors
on peut faire un partage strict des
voiries mais ça c'est pas forcément la
solution mais ça peut en être une quand
même
on peut par exemple isoler les bus ou
faire en sorte que les pistes cyclables
soient plus utilisées que les piétons
traversent bien au niveau des
stationnements enfin il y a un peu
une prise en compte de chacun de ces
différentes problématiques vous vous
déplacez comment sur l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin chacun moi je suis venu en
vélo
et j'ai la chance de travailler à
Saint-Quentin s'il fait que j'utilise
qu'une chaîne de dans les transports
possibles
voilà et puis on peut effectivement
conjuguer utiliser donc soit le vélo
soit la voiture les transports en commun
en fonction de ses besoins et il faut
juste que le territoire s'y adapté il
faut des témoignages comme le vôtre
puisque j'imagine que vous livrerez
aussi votre témoignage alors de ces
ateliers débats qui se déroulent le 4
avril juste pour conclure pour inciter
les gens à venir pour leur dire quoi
parce qu'on en parle souvent de ces
problématiques il faut se déplacer écolo
mais pour que les gens n'aient pas le
sentiment de venir pour se faire taper
sur les doigts non plus vous leur diriez
quoi non alors pas taper sur les doigts
pas du tout c'est absolument pas notre
objectif mais
l'objectif de ces tables rondes c'est
justement de d'avoir un maximum de
témoignages pour pouvoir vraiment
proposer des actions concrètes et
des avis d'usagers de Saint-Quentin donc
qui soit habitant ou étudiants ou
salarié ce sont les utilisateurs des
transports en commun ou des voiries de
Saint-Quentin qui pourront nous aider
dans l'amélioration de mieux vivre
ensemble
le mot de la fin que c'est une des
actions donc auxquelles contribue le
codeski et ça s'ajoute à ça
l'implication dans les plans à échelle
le plus régionales comme le Plan de
Déplacement Urbain de l'Île-de-France et
le schéma directeur régional de
l'Île-de-France auquel dans lequel
s'implique l'ensemble des membres des
codesquis se déplacer écologique si vous
aussi vous voulez mettre votre petite
pierre à cette échafaudage qui commence
à monter et qui permet à chacun
d'utiliser le mode de transport qu'il
est le plus adapté à lui que ce soit le
vélo on l'a entendu tout à l'heure avec
votre témoignage ou encore les bus ou le
train se déplacer écologique jeudi 4
avril 18h30 communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin c'est à trappe et la
semaine du développement durable qui a
des débutés aujourd'hui va se poursuivre
le programme complet est sur le site de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines la suite du 7 8 toujours avec
cette problématique de l'environnement
mais avec du recyclage la deuxième vie
des bacs de tennis c'est très sérieux il
sera aussi la question de sport avec
l'équipe des Cougars de Montigny y le
Bretonneux du baseball Montigny qui vise
le plus haut niveau pour l'instant en
retour sur le week-end de Pâques et ses
traditionnels chasse aux œufs avec ce
reportage de Claire Combier
dans ce champ des œufs de Pâques
derrière chaque touffe d'herbe un énorme
terrain de jeu pour ses enfants partis à
la chasse aux œufs lundi à la ferme de
Gally petits et grands remplissaient
leur panier et chacun avait sa propre
technique
je suis allée très vite pour les
ramasser et c'est pour ça que j'en ai eu
beaucoup j'en prenais plein dans mes
mains et après je les mettais dans le
panier
toutes les méthodes étaient bonnes bon
il faut dire aussi que les œufs
n'étaient pas très bien cachés les
organisateurs ont dû faire face à une
grosse affluence 6000 personnes sur la
journée et le plus difficile à gérer ce
n'était pas les enfants
plus cela c'est les parents en fait qui
attaquent les animateurs juste pour
prendre des eaux en plastique et pas
forcément les jeunes c'est des parents
qui jouent plus le jeu le jeu que les
enfants
des parents qui retrouvent une âme
d'enfant pour chasser les œufs mais
aussi dans les différents ateliers
proposés autour de Pâques comme la
fabrication de nids
mais où sont donc partie les enfants ah
ils sont ici en train de peindre les
œufs au programme on pouvait aussi
compter sur un atelier chocolat ou
encore la rencontre avec ses animaux de
la ferme
allez c'est la fin de la journée il est
temps d'échanger les œufs ramassés
contre de vrais œufs en chocolat et ces
chocolats c'est pour les adultes aussi
mais bien sûr
je n'y résiste pas c'est certain